Everyone.
Welcome,
welcome,
welcome in to another edition of Market Takes.
It is a beautiful day to dissect some economic data to the sun is shining.
The birds are chirping.
I don't know you could have been anywhere in the world,
but you are here with me and I appreciate that.
I am Dion Rabo reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Today we are diving into unpacking explaining the C P I Consumer
Price Index Report.
C P I just came out this morning.
Uh The markets are having a reaction in a pretty big way.
I think the reaction we've seen especially on the stock prices from the stock markets and from
commodities has been very interesting.
So we're going to get into what all that was and why all that was here in just a sec.
But of course,
we're going to talk about what the C P I report said,
break down what those headline numbers were as well as get under the surface and explain how those numbers
compared to expectations.
Uh We're also going to talk about the biggest takeaway.
I think there's one big takeaway you can get from today's report in terms of looking at all the other data that
we've seen.
We're of course going to talk about the,
how this report changes or moves expectations for what we think the Federal
Reserve is going to do next,
or at least what investors think the Federal Reserve is going to do next.
We're going to take a look at the markets.
Like I said,
we're going to talk stocks,
bonds,
commodities.
We're gonna talk a little bit about those currency markets as well.
So stay tuned for that.
And we're gonna explain what today's report tells us about the future and what to look for
next.
So without further ado,
let's get into it,
the C P I report today showed 4.9% year over year inflation in
April as well as a 0.4% increase in uh inflation
month over month.
So as you look here,
this is the year over year chart that we've got up here right now on your screen and you can see we've
seen inflation consistently come down since that peak in June when inflation at 9%
it's been coming down.
And this month we had 4.9% last month,
it was 5% the month before that,
it was six going all the way back up.
And you see that consistent downturn in C P I inflation and you see it's been
coming down,
that's what the market wants to see.
That's what the Federal Reserve wants to see uh and this has been right along with expectations for
5% year over year,
a little bit below that at 4.9 point 4% month,
over month,
right over the right on the numbers.
Now,
I wanna put this other chart up here on your screen and that is the core consumer price index.
That's when you strip out food and energy prices which are very volatile.
So the fed likes to see OK,
what's happening at the core of the market or of the of the economy right now with
inflation?
And as you look,
you see those numbers not quite moving along the same trajectory,
you see a consistent downturn since June in terms of the numbers moving lower.
But in the last few months,
we saw a pick up last month,
core inflation actually rose to 5.6% year over year,
last month.
And this month coming in,
I'm sorry,
in April coming in at 5.5%.
So core inflation being a bit more stubborn than the overall inflation in terms of coming
down.
And that's maybe got some folks on the market side worried.
So got from some folks on the market side a little worried I should say
and this illustrating that trend that we've seen overall in markets.
So what we've got is the core C P I.
When you take out shelter,
core C P I services,
shelter,
that's the super core metric that also decreased to 0.266% month,
over month,
down from 0.294% month over month,
last month.
Uh All those numbers mean is that the feds,
what the fed has said is the most important thing to watch.
Now,
core super core inflation or super core C P I inflation,
it's mouthful.
Um what the fed has said to watch that super core number has been coming down while overall inflation is coming
down,
core coming down just a little bit at the margins.
But coming down,
everything kind of moving in the right direction,
the direction the fed wants to see it in.
That's got markets a little bit excited.
Now,
when we talk about what's moving up and what's moving down this report because not everything moves in the same
direction as the overall index,
right?
So we saw transportation services down month,
over month,
medical care services down month,
over month.
So overall the services reading on the C P I number moved lower but
it's still up year over year.
So month,
over month,
the trend is coming down.
But year over year,
we see we are still up and still higher.
Uh get into the the context,
the nuts and bolts just a little bit more.
I want to read you a quote from Goldman Sachs Asset Management this morning,
they said quote the below 5% headline C P I number is a sigh of relief to a
market on edge the data today will be interpreted as not hot enough to force the fed's
hand in June,
the fed has an excuse now not to hike.
In fact,
the market's first reaction to is to price that the fed will be done.
And I think we're seeing that in markets gonna talk about that in just a second.
So listen,
one thing I saw,
I saw a very interesting quote in my inbox this morning.
It said this report confirms C P I is trending as expected.
What does that mean?
Well,
that's bullish.
That means the markets.
There's not a new worry introduced to the markets,
there's not,
you know anything that's oh goodness.
Now we gotta worry about inflation picking back up or moving in a direction.
We didn't expect market is pricing that inflation is going to get back down to words
or close to the fed's 2% target by the end of the year that's been priced in.
And that's what you're seeing in the stock market in the bond market is expectations for that to happen.
So for this report to come in as expected,
you were seeing a continuation of those themes.
What's driving inflation?
We saw a huge jump in used car prices up 4.4% over the month.
Um 4.4% month over month is a big huge number and we know how much use
car prices moved.
Uh the C P I figures last year and coming into the start of,
well,
actually really at the end of 2021 into 2022 then that is
started to fade away.
So used car prices have not been as much of an increase or a push up on overall
inflation.
We saw a big jump in that number.
Uh The index for Shelter was the largest contributor to the monthly all items increase.
This is straight from the B L S S report followed by increases the index for used cars and trucks
and the index for gasoline.
So we know that all of those things if we look at the real time indicators and if we look at the
consistent trends have been moving lower.
So the fact they picked up one month,
well,
the market saying,
ok,
that may be a one month aberration that might just be happening this month.
We don't think that's gonna continue.
And so that's again,
good news for this overall inflation theme.
Now,
if we see uh gasoline prices continue to pick up,
if we see used car prices continue to pick up,
that might be worrisome for the market because these are worries that we thought we were done with that.
We thought,
oh yeah,
that's in the past.
And so investors are really kind of looking past those increases and saying overall this is a good
thing.
Now,
a big piece of this could be the index for gasoline,
the increase in the gasoline index more than offset declines in other energy component
indexes and the energy index overall rose 0.6%.
All that means is that overall you've got energy picking up even though fuel,
oil,
uh natural gas,
things like that declined.
Diesel overall,
gasoline prices increased.
What we're seeing at the pump is rising and that has a big impact on consumer psyche folks when they see
those prices rising at the pump,
they think,
oh man,
inflation might be coming back.
Prices are gonna rise.
I need to demand more at work.
I need to try and get a raise because I've got to keep up with these overall inflation prices.
I was just in Phoenix recently saw gas prices over $5 a gallon.
Uh just a couple of weeks ago in Phoenix,
the US average is 3 $53.03 dollars and 53 cents a gallon versus 3 60 a
month ago versus 4 37 years ago a year ago.
So again,
trend moving in the right direction,
but it's a it it remains to be seen whether that will continue.
We've also got the food index being unchanged.
We know that food has been a big consistent part of this overall inflation story.
Food was unchanged in April again,
it was unchanged in March as well.
Index for food at home uh declining.
That had been something that had been really spiking up what you're paying at the grocery store had been picking up on a big,
on a big level that's going down this month.
While the index for food away from home rose 0.4% index for airline fares,
the index for new vehicles were among those that decrease.
So airline price is getting a little bit cheaper.
That's good to see as we approach the summer flying months when a lot of Americans do traveling.
Um Listen,
one thing that we don't want to forget and one thing that I pointed out in our look ahead earlier this
week was corporate profits,
corporate profit margins in are on pace to increase for the first quarter.
Once we get all those earnings reports,
we will know whether corporate profits picked up and increased again.
Right now,
it looks like they will.
And that was a huge driver.
In fact,
the main driver of overall inflation increases that we saw last year that led to
that big 9% increase year over year we are seeing right now.
S and P net profit margins,
which means the amount of profit that companies are making for every dollar of sales
increased its on pace to rise the first quarter in six quarters,
it decreased six straight quarters.
And now it's expected to increase.
We continue on this trajectory.
It's up 11.5% from what it was a year ago.
Now,
keep in mind that corporate profit number,
corporate net profit margins up 11.5% that compares to
4.9% 4.9% overall inflation and
2.7% increase in producer prices,
A K A wholesale prices or what companies are paying.
So,
companies,
prices are increasing at about 2.7% and their net profit margins are
increasing 11.5%.
That puts more upward pressure on inflation.
That's something you're going to want to keep an eye on is the role that company profits play in
inflation.
The oil,
oil companies as well have seen big profit margin gains and that could be part of why
prices at the pump are still high.
Even though overall oil prices have declined pretty significantly,
keep your eye on that.
And that's why you want to watch out for those reports,
those earnings reports from oil companies because even though oil prices are declining and coming down
from their highs,
oil companies are just keeping prices high,
keeping that difference as profit.
So let's take a step back now and talk about expectations for the Federal Reserve.
The market very clearly after this report came out was betting the Federal Reserve is gonna
pause at its June meeting and then start cutting rates again soon.
And an interesting development in the fed funds futures market.
Uh,
we're seeing an increased increasing bets on a rate cut in July.
Folks had really been betting,
the fed was going to start cutting rates in September and that was sort of the move that was priced in.
But after the C P I report came out,
we saw a move in fed funds futures prices showing a 36% likelihood of a
cut in July.
All that means is that folks think that ok with inflation slowing down,
even though it's still more than double the fed's 2% target,
folks are betting that in just a couple of months,
we could see a fed rate cut as soon as July 36% chance of that.
And if you go out to September,
you're seeing a rate cut,
a rate cut fully priced in with a 22% chance of two rate
cuts as soon as September or a 50 basis point rate cut.
Basically the fed cutting the equivalent of two rate cuts or maybe cutting in July and again in September,
that is big for the market because it not only signifies that folks don't believe what the
fed says.
Remember the Federal reserve fed chair,
Jerome said we are not cutting rates.
We are going to keep rates elevated even though we may be pausing for right now.
We are going to keep rates at this high level through the end of the year or maybe even raise them if
inflation starts to pick back up.
Uh,
the market saying not only do we not believe you,
we think you're gonna start cutting,
we think you're gonna start cutting soon that the rubber is gonna meet the road here very quickly.
The fed,
if they're going to cut in July is gonna have to signal that in June that could see,
we could see some big market moves in June or in July.
Uh,
so watch that,
watch this space as I like to say,
um,
that is holding stock prices up because folks expect,
ok,
companies are having a tough time now,
but we think that things are gonna change pretty soon and that could push those stock prices up.
So we're not gonna sell,
we're not gonna get out of stocks.
It's also pushing those bond yields down,
making it cheaper for companies to borrow money.
Um Wanna throw one more chart up here on your screen and this is going to show the difference
between what we're looking at in terms of big companies versus small companies.
This is the net percentage of us banks lending standards.
What that means is what percentage of banks in the fed study are making it
harder for you to get a loan,
making it harder to give businesses loans.
Whether the small businesses,
this is more mid size and large companies.
But how tough is it to get a loan?
Are you requiring higher credit scores?
Are you requiring more collateral?
Are you requiring a longer relationship?
And this right here is showing 46% of banks are increasing those lending standards,
making it harder for folks to get a loan harder for businesses to get loan and we know that this
affects smaller companies more than bigger companies.
So while,
while conditions have been easier for large companies that can issue stock or
issue bonds out on capital markets,
conditions have gotten significantly tighter and more difficult to get money for these small
businesses.
And as we can see it,
we've already risen into recession level conditions when it comes to the net percentage of
us banks tightening lending standards whenever it's gotten this tight before I,
you see there on your screen,
we have had a recession.
So keep your eye on that.
But also it's interesting to note that we didn't get a big pick up this last,
we the,
we just have the reporting period in from April.
Um and we didn't get a big pick up between April and January as we're expecting after Silicon
Valley bank collapse after first Republic and all that.
So we didn't get a big pick up there.
So that just illustrates like I said that it's harder right now for companies to borrow money,
especially the smaller ones,
but not getting a lot harder as a lot of folks would expect it as a lot of folks would have
expected.
Now,
let's talk about it and let's take a look at what's going on in the markets.
I wanna put up here on your screen,
what we're seeing overall in the stock market,
the bond market.
Now,
initially,
when that C P I report came out,
you saw stocks open up higher.
Uh And this is the Dow Jones industrial average right now.
And then as folks kind of digested,
you saw the stock prices really drop and even went negative and we are back up positive.
Now,
just a little bit.
The Dow is up about 0.1%.
The now,
NASDAQ up 1.13% want to show you just for,
for context here,
the five day chart.
Uh and you see right here,
boom,
just a big take off this morning.
And that really all came after that C P I report was released.
You see a big pick up,
especially on the NASDAQ because the NASDAQ has those tech names that are much more impacted by the
Federal Reserve's rate hiking uh cycle.
And we have seen those pick up significantly.
Stocks are way up for the NASDAQ.
You see up 1% versus half percent for the S and P and just a little bit over a
0.1% on the dow.
When we look out here at the bond prices,
we're seeing the 30 year down a little bit,
but I wanna take you into the yields that are much more impacted by fed expectations.
The two year note,
you see a huge drop and that comes right after 8 30 when we got that C P I
report bond yields going down,
which means prices going up.
Basically,
folks saying I want to buy bonds because I think yields are gonna be lower.
I think the fed is gonna cut rates.
I think that inflation is going to keep coming down.
And that just illustrating overall what we've seen from the markets.
Uh On that side of things,
you also saw similar things happening with oil prices,
with copper prices.
Gold actually had picked up initially after the C P I report came out and then came back down.
So that was what we had seen from markets in reaction to the data we got this morning.
Listen,
big step back.
What are we looking at?
The effect on the current narrative is folks are expecting that the economy will get a little rough.
The fed will cut rates and that that will be good for especially risky stock
prices and risky assets like things like oil.
Um We expect rate cuts is what the market is saying as soon as July pricing
goes in a little bit sooner than September.
But there is no doubt right now in the market,
the market is,
has a 0% likelihood right now that by December,
the fed will have rates where it has them right now.
And I said,
I'll say it again,
0% likelihood is what the market is seeing as the fed keeping rates at its level.
Right now,
market is pricing in at least three cuts from the fed by December and there are some
expectations now for four rate cuts.
That's big.
Um What's next?
Well,
we've got more data coming out this week.
P P I,
the producer price index will be out um,
on Thursday,
that's coming up tomorrow.
And again,
that report showing 2.7% increase year over year for producers.
So that is just really come down significantly and moving towards the fed's target for C
P I 2.2%.
Now,
that's important because we have seen for a long time P P I lead C P I.
So you're gonna want to watch that.
We also get the Empire State manufacturing report on Monday that usually is not highly watched.
But those numbers have been so bad over the course of this year.
Every report we've seen from Fed Manufacturing survey has just been bad,
negative if not negative by 10 20 points.
Uh It's been at least on the below zero side.
So watch out for that one on,
on Monday.
If we get another very negative print,
it could be an ominous sign for the overall state of manufacturing,
maybe for recession expectations.
We will be talking right here on Monday.
Market takes will give you your look ahead.
And next week we have us retail sales on Tuesday.
We'll be talking about all that.
Listen,
I'm your host,
Dion Rabo reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
This has been market takes.
I thank you so much for being with us and I hope you'll be with us again,
next time.